>> THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
COMMITTED TO THE REFUGEE
PROGRAM AND TO REBUILDING IT
AND REGAINING OUR STATUS AS A
WORLD LEADER IN THE REFUGEE
AFFAIRS SINCE DAY ONE.
AND THAT HAS BEEN UNWAVERING.
WE’RE VERY PROUD OF THE
ANNOUNCEMENT TODAY AND IT
REFLECTS AN ENDURING COMMITMENT.
>> Dana: HOMELAND SECURITY
SECRETARY MAYORKAS ON PRESIDENT
BIDEN’S DECISION TO QUADRUPLE
IMMIGRATION.
FORMER ACTING ICE DIRECTOR TOM
HOMAN JOINS US NOW.
EXPLAIN TO MEME THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN SOMEBODY WHO IS
CROSSING ILLEGALLY VERSUS THE
REFUGEE PROGRAM.
>> LET ME RESPOND TO WHAT THE
SECRETARY SAID ABOUT RESTORING
OUR LEADERSHIP IN THE REFUGEE
PROGRAM.
FIRST OF ALL WHAT THEY FAIL TO
TELL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IS
THAT WE LEAD THE WORLD IN THE
NUMBER OF IMMIGRANTS THAT WE
WELCOME TO THIS COUNTRY.
WE HAVE 45 MILLION IMMIGRANTS
IN THIS COUNTRY.
OUT OF ALL THE MIGRATION IN THE
WORLD MIGRANT POPULATION THE
UNITED STATES HAS 20%.
EVEN THOUGH IT’S 195 COUNTRIES
WE HAVE 20%.
WE WELCOME MORE THAN 1.1
MILLION IMMIGRANTS TO THIS
COUNTRY EVER YEAR.
WE ALREADY ARE THE WORLD’S
LEADER AND THE MOST GIVING
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
AS FAR AS THE REFUGEE PROGRAM
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT APPLY
FROM HOME COUNTRIES ESCAPING
FEAR AND PERSECUTION AND THE
MOST SERIOUS AND AGAIN
PRESIDENT TRUMP DECREASED THAT
NUMBER AND JOE BIDEN AGREED TO
12,000 AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
YEAR.
ONCE AGAIN HE FOLDED TO THE
PROGRESSIVE LEFT.
HE SOLD OUT TO THE PROGRESSIVE
LEFT TO WIN THE COLLECTION.
HE USED TO BELIEVE IN
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT AND
BORDER BARRIERS.
BECAUSE HE WANTED THE VOTES
FROM THE PROGRESSIVE LEFT I
WILL STOP THE REMAIN IN MEXICO
PROGRAM AND OTHERS.
THIS IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE.
HE MADE THE RIGHT DECISION AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR BUT
FOLDED TO PROGRESSIVE LEFT
AGAIN.
IT DOESN’T MAKE SENSE.
IT IS A BAD TIME WHEN THE
BORDER IS OUT OF CONTROL TO
INCREASE THAT CAP.
>> Dana: AND THERE IS ALSO THIS.
THERE WAS THE -- ADMINISTRATION
WILL ANNOUNCE $4 BILLION IN
FOREIGN AID TO THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE COUNTRY.
KAMALA HARRIS SAID THAT’S WHAT
SHE WILL BE IN CHARGE OF.
DOING DIPLOMACY WITH THEM.
HERE IS MONEY COMING.
THEY WROTE THIS.
IT IS WORRISOME THE
ADMINISTRATION’S SOLUTION ISN’T
TO REINSTATE THE POLICIES OR
REPLACE THEM WITH WORKABLE
SOLUTIONS BUT PAY MORE MONEY TO
DISSUADE THEIR CITIZENS WITH
CORRUPTION ISSUES, THAT’S REAL
IN THOSE COUNTRIES, TOM.
>> IT IS REAL.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DIDN’T PAY
RANSOM.
HE HAD AGREEMENTS WITH ALL
THESE COUNTRIES.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
DESTROYED THEM ON DAY ONE EVEN
THOUGH THEY WERE WORKING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WASN’T PAYING
RAN SOME.
WE’VE GIVEN THESE COUNTRIES
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
IT DOESN’T WORK.
THEY CAN MAKE A FEW DOLLARS IF
THEY STAY IN THEIR HOME COUNTRY
OR THEY CAN COME THEY SEE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE COMING TO
OUR BORDERS AND SEE THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE BEING RELEASED AND
NOT BEING DETAINED.
THEY KNOW THEY CAN GET A JOB
HERE BECAUSE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS STOPPED ICE
FROM DOING WORK ENFORCEMENT
OPERATIONS.
COME HERE, NOT BE DETAINED, BE
RELEASED, GET A JOB HERE BASED
ON OTHER PROMISES THEY’LL GET
FREE HEALTHCARE.
WHY WOULD YOU NOT WANT TO COME
TO THE GREATEST COUNTRY ON
EARTH?
THIS IS NOT GOING THE WORK.
WE’VE DONE THIS OVER AND OVER
AGAIN AND THE SECOND THING I’LL
SAY, YOU CAN’T BUY THESE
COUNTRIES WITH THE FEW BILLION
DOLLARS.
MEXICO ALONE RECEIVED OVER $40
BILLION REMITTANCE PAYMENTS
FROM ILLEGAL ALIENS SENDING THE
MONEY BACK TO MEXICO.
$40 BILLION IN THE MEXICAN
ECONOMY.
THEY DIDN’T HAVE THE TRAIN THE
PEOPLE AND PROVIDE THEM SOCIAL
SERVICES.
YOU CAN’T OUTSPEND THIS.
NONE OF THE COUNTRIES WANT TO
STOP ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
BECAUSE THEY MAKE SO MUCH MONEY
ON THE REMITTANCES.
>> Dana: THAT’S AN IMPORTANT
POINT.
HOW WOULD YOU SPEND $4 BILLION
NOW IF YOU HAD -- IF THEY GAVE
YOU THAT MONEY AND SAID HELP
SOLVE THE CRISIS AT THE BORDER,
WHAT WOULD YOU DO?
>> CONTINUE BUILDING THE WALLS
BECAUSE THE WALLS WORK.
THE SURGE IS COMING RIGHT NOW,
THEY ARE COMING WHERE THERE IS
NOT A WALL.
DATA SHOWS EVERY PLACE THEY
BUILT A WALL ILLEGAL DRUGS AND
IMMIGRATION WENT DOWN.
I’VE BEEN DOWN TO THE BORDER.
IF WE HAD A WALL WE WOULDN’T
GET THE SURGE WE HAVE.
IT WOULD FORCE MIGRANTS TO A
PORT OF ENTRY WHERE THEY DON’T
HAVE TO PAY CRIMINAL CARTELS
AND CHILDREN WON’T DROWN IN THE
RIVER.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATIONS HAS
CREATED AN INHUMANE SYSTEM.
CHILDREN ARE DYING.
WOMEN GETTING SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED.
MORE DEATHS ON THAT BORDER
BECAUSE OF THE POLICIES OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.